[Music]
talk to me about being here and white
sand for free to be involved every day I
love the whole idea of Honda just
getting kids especially involved in
philanthropy and giving back obviously
you know my family is big on that I
learned that from my father
it's about making this world a better
place and everybody has a part in that
everyone is special you know everyone is
math necessarily be like Muhammad Ali
right but at the same time you can do
something in your community to make the
world a better place
you brought up your father it's been
almost a year since his death what is
the best piece of advice he passed down
to you basically you know the service
that you're doing giving back is you
know your rent that you're paying here
on earth and in heaven he's to say that
so we're here on earth to give back it's
not all about us and he really did truly
live his life that way so you know we
want to lead by example for these kids I
read something recently about you where
you said he actually encouraged you not
to get into boxing is that is that true
it is he wasn't necessarily excited that
his daughter his youngest daughter a
girl and a woman because my father
didn't feel that women should fight and
he didn't feel his daughter to fight and
I had to just go in there and show them
that I could and I was going to and you
know I changed his mind about it which
was a big win he actually said to me wow
girl you can't fight a women can
because they saw me fighting for the
women that were I was fighting to saw
the skill and he changed his mind so I
was really some special to me he
obviously inspired that perseverance in
you oh for sure I mean but I believed in
myself regardless of whether or not he
did my mom is actually the one that from
the beginning was like he could do
anything to tomorrow so luckily I looked
at her at him
[Music]